bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat les sénateurs ont donc
voté dans la nuit les deux projets de
loi sur la transparence de la vie
publique sans toutefois adopté la
principale disposition de ces deux
textes à savoir la publication au
journal officiel du patrimoine des élus
s'étaient pourtant la réponse du
gouvernement à la sphère cahuzac
alors cet après midi députés et
sénateurs vont se réunir pour trouver un
texte de compromis avant un vote
définitif de ce projet de loi qui
devrait intervenir d'ici la fin juillet
en attendant ce matin en retour sur le
vote de cette nuit bonne matinée à tous
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
la séance est reprise je vous donne
lecture des résultats du scrutin numéro
3 115 sur les amendements numéro 50
rectifié 90 rectifier à l'article 11
nombre de votants 345 nombre de
suffrages exprimés
342 au l'adoption 172 contre 170 donc
les amendements sont 50 rectifier et 90
rectifié sont adoptés et l'article 11
est supprimé
en conséquence les amendements prévus
cet article tombe et nous en arrivons
donc après à l'article 11 à un
amendement 88 rectifié de monsieur
ruquier s'est brillamment celui du chat
collègues legacy se demande locale et
l'honneur la compétition électorale ne
saurait cependant être faussés par un
avantage indu dont bénéficierait un
candidat par rapport aux autres
notamment en raison des fonctions qu'ils
exercent c'est bien pour cette raison
que le corps électoral prévoit d
incompatibilité entre ses deux fonctions
exercées des mandats locaux
c'est un logique est pas nouvelle
puisque les premiers en compte une
compatibilité été fixée à la fin du
dîner ème siècle à l'espèce l'estiment
que les membres des cabinets
ministériels doit pas pouvoir se
présenter aux élections locales à raison
de la position avantageuse dont
bénéficient à raison de leurs fonctions
qui les amène notamment à exercer une
autorité son administration ses
raisonnements aujourd'hui incompatibles
un mandat électoral avec les fonctions
de préfet de certains direction
d'organisations de territoriales ont le
directeur de cabinet d'exécutifs locaux
ils appartiennent dont il nous semble
donc cohérent d'appliquer le même
raisonnement aux membres des cabinets
ministériels démesurée qui avis de la
commission monsieur le président
monsieur riquier je suis étonné car que
lorsque nous avons discuté de cet
amendement en commission
j'avais sollicité des rectifications et
on m'avait assuré que ces rectifications
serait faite
or en l'état actuel des choses nous ne
pouvons pas adopter cet amendement je
vais vous dire pourquoi
premièrement tel qu'il est rédigé il
interdirait le cumul entre des fonctions
de membre d'un cabinet ministériel
autres collaborateurs du président de la
république et les fonctions de député
mais non les fonctions de sénateur
de la même manière il interdirait le
cumul avec un mandat de conseiller
général
mais non de conseiller régional
je redis enfin qu'il y a un problème de
constitutionnalité puisqu'il fixe
c'est à cet amendement fixe une
incompatibilité avec le mandat
parlementaire et pour justifier que cela
soit cela doit relever de la loi
organique
en vertu de l'article 25 de la
constitution donc l'avis est défavorable
en l'état parce que ce n'est pas une loi
organique
et il ya des incohérences interne merci
à vis du gouvernement que j'ai ma vie
mais ma vie donc deux avis défavorables
quels sont ceux qui sont pour l'adoption
de l'art de l'amendement 88 rectifié
avis contraire
il n'est pas adoptée après l'article 11
amendements 89 rectifié deux jours
monsieur mais il s'agit cette fois des
collaborateurs du président de la
république dont on peut penser a priori
qui exercent une autorité encore plus
importante et bénéficie donc d'une
position plus engagé si même avis de la
commission même avis du gouvernement
même vote
il ne pas adopter un amendement 5 qu'il
tombe le 7 aussi amendement 86 rectifié
monsieur réquier où monsieur collombat
les membres des cabinets ministériels
exercé des fonctions importantes et puis
qu'il fallait exercer l'autorité sur
l'administration dans leur ministre a la
charge ou encore pour avoir inventé le
ministre soumis à des contraintes de
droit public y aura accès à des
informations sensibles se posant
décideurs des points de vue il est donc
pas concevable que ces personnes dans
les fonctions exige une mobilisation à
30 ans puisse exercer d'autres fonctions
rénumérés ou non a fortiori si elles se
situent à la frontière d'intérêt public
et du privé
nous proposons donc à proscrire ce cumul
d'activités sous quelque forme qu'il
soit y compris par exemple sous celle du
statut d'auto entrepreneur
merci avec la commission monsieur le
président l'avis de la commission est
défavorable nous avons connu un brillant
professeur de droit qui a porté et qui
malheureusement nous a quittés qui
apporte un concours très utile à des
cabinets ministériels
merci à vis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
oui le même avis
considérons gouvernement considère qu'
il n'est pas nécessaire d'interdire une
activité par exemple d'enseignant y
compris bénévoles et et donc cela
justifie qu'à nos yeux et au regard du
fait que l'ensemble des déclarations
d'intérêts des membres du cabinet seront
publiques ce qui sera une bonne manière
de lutter contre les abus
le gouvernement donne un avis
défavorable à cet amendement
si mashako mamba pour explication de
vote je suis un peu étonné de ces
réponses dans la mesure où nous sommes
ce pas parti pour la transparence pour
la vertu et c'est alors je veux bien que
effectivement sur le sur le plan des
principes on peut imaginer que healy a
parmi les professeurs parmi tous les
gens qui ont une activité
professionnelle les gens qui peuvent et
emine à porter des habits éminent à au
cabinet de tel ou tel ministre ou du
président de la république
mais précisément on est en train
d'essayer de deux mètres des cloisons
entre ce que font les uns est ce que
font les autres
quand vous êtes membre de cabinet
ministériel c'est peu compatibles me
semblait-il avec la fonction d'auto
entrepreneur on a eu des exemples
récents ou avec l'exercice d'autres
d'autres pour d'autres professions je
veux dire que encore une fois membre
d'un cabinet c'est l'action prise des
décisions c'est là que sont préparées
les textes c'est là s'il y a vraiment si
le il ya des risques de président et de
conflits d'intérêts
c'est là que ça se passe c'est pas ici
bien qu'on appelait parler d'abord de ça
donc on a été extrêmement rigoureux
s'agissant des cumuls de fonctions
d'activité avec les parlementaires mais
s'agissant de ceux qui ont finalement le
pouvoir de préparer les décisions bien
on trouve ça tout à fait naturel c'est
un peu c'est un peu étrange
que effectivement ça ça rejoint le
remarque que je faisais c'est que le
problème de notre vème république
finissante
c'est la concentration des pouvoirs dans
l'exécutif sous toutes ses formes
mais c'est bien sûr parce que laquelle
pouvoir on attend peine à toucher à ce
pouvoir on y touche qu'avec une main
tremblante
pourtant c'est là qu'il faudrait faire
le ménage
si tant est qu'il y ait des ménages à
faire merci je mets donc aux voix
l'amendement 86 rectifié qui a reçu
l'avis défavorable de la commission et
de gouvernement quels sont ceux qui sont
pour son adoption
avis contraire il n'est pas adoptée
après l'article 11 amendements 87
rectifié toujours monsieur réquier celui
de sa collègue c'est la même rendement
mais pour les collaborateurs des
cabinets 2d comme le collaborateur
direct du président république a
considéré qu' il s' assez occupé à
aiguiser sa créativité ailleurs dit même
avis de la commission des gouvernements
même vote
il n'est pas adopté un amendement 96
tombe
l'amendement 168 de la commission
monsieur le président c'est un
amendement de clarification monsieur le
président merci à vis du gouvernement
favorable je le mets au wa quels sont
ceux qui sont pour l'amendement de
monsieur sueur au nom de la commission
avis contraire il est adopté
article 11 bis à un amendement de la
commission monsieur de réparer une
erreur monsieur le président merci avait
dû grandement favorable monsieur le
ministre
favorable quels sont ceux qui sont pour
l'adoption un bis contraire je n'en vois
pas il est adopté je mets aux voix
l'article 11 bis
à quels sont ceux qui sont pour adopter
l'article 6 à henvic contraire il est
adopté
après l'article 11 bis à un amendement 6
qui tombe
un article 11 bis un amendement 10 qui
tombe un hammam
leur amendement numéro neuf tombes le
huit tombes amendement 184 de monsieur
sueur gide la correction d'une erreur
monsieur le président favorable je le
revois quels sont ceux qui sont pour
l'adoption du 184 avis contraire il est
adopté le 11 tomber je mets aux voix
l'article 11 bis quels sont ceux qui
sont pour l'adoption de l'article 11 bis
avis contraire il est adopté article
après l'article 11 bis un amendement 12
qui tombe un amendement 13 qui tombe un
amendement 14 qui lui aussi tombe un
amendement 108 qui tombe
nous en arrivons l'article 11 ter avec
un amendement 75 qui tombe et 80
demandes en discussion commune dont le
131 de monsieur ziani c'est un
amendement qui prévoit que les partis
politiques dans des conditions fixées
par décret comme unique chaque année à
la commission nationale des comptes de
campagne et des financements politiques
la liste des personnes ayant consenti
annuellement à verser un ou plusieurs
dons ou cotisation il le 77 ongles 54
semble 105 tombes et je demande donc
l'avis de la commission sur l'amendement
131 rectifié de monsieur anziani
la commission considère que l'amendement
131 de monsieur ziani est
particulièrement judicieux
parce qu'il va dans le sens de la
transparence d'une barre et accroît les
moyens d'action de la commission des
comptes de campagne
merci à vis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
je mets donc on voit l'amendement de
monsieur anziani 131 rectifié qui a reçu
l'avis favorable de la commission et du
gouvernement
quels sont ceux qui sont pour son
adoption avis contraire il est adopté un
amendement 29 rectifié madame boulet oui
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues il s'agit
d'un amendement tout aussi pertinent que
celui de monsieur en génie puisqu'il
vise à interdire aux personnes physiques
étrangères sauf si elles ont des
lectrices en france ou au titre
d'accords internationaux communautaire
de financer les campagnes électorales
si avis de la commission monsieur le
président sur l'amendement 29,2 me faire
rouler la commission s'en remet à la
sagesse du sénat
merci avait du gouvernement sagesse
monsieur prison merci je mets donc on
voit l'amendement de madame goulet qui a
reçu la double avis de sagesse du
gouvernement et de la commission quels
sont ceux qui sont pour son adoption
un vue contraire il est adopté je mets
au voile article austère quels sont ceux
qui sont pour l'adoption de cet article
11 ter avis contraire je n'en vois pas
il est adopté après l'article 11 d'air
deux amendements qui tombe celui de
monsieur le comte et celui de madame
lipietz de même que le quinze de
monsieur masson de même que le sens est
de madame lipietz à monsieur le
président en sueur je vous en prie parce
que nous avons atteint une rapidité qui
n'est pas encore celle du personnage qui
a grimpé le mont ventoux hier mais
toutefois elle commence à être assez
remarquable alors je voulais vous dire
monsieur le président que je reprenais
l'amendement 76 de monsieur le comte
puisqu'il prévoit de mieux tenir compte
des nouvelles dispositions de l'article
11 4 de la loi du 11 mars 88 modifié par
l'article 11 ter de ce projet de loi dès
lors que les dons versés par une
une personne physique s'adresse à
plusieurs partis politiques ceux ci
n'ont pas la possibilité de s'assurer du
respect de la loi par ses donateurs
il convient dans ce cas de les exclure
de ces mesures de sanction gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
bon je vais pas filer la métaphore
cycliste même si les foi ont comme des
montagnes aussi vite qu on les descend
mais l'avis favorable
merci jamais donc aux voix l'amendement
76 rectifié qui devient l'amendement 196
et qui a reçu l'avis favorable du
gouvernement quels sont ceux qui sont
pour son adoption
avis contraire il est adopté
nous en arrivons donc à l'amendement 107
qui tombe le sang neuf même sort le 113
également et nous avons l'amendement 153
madame du kerman
il s'agit ici de d'intégrer la question
du lobbying
dès lors que nous parlons de conflit
d'intérêts puisque même si en tant que
parlementaire il est je crois tout à
fait normal que nous soyons à l'écouté
de ce qui se passe dans la société
lorsque l'on est labourons les
différentes lois
nous ne pouvons pas en revanche accepté
les dérives d'un système de lobbying qui
prend bien trop souvent des apparences
de corruption les invitations pour 2
coûte repas les voyages d'études les
cadeaux divers peuvent donner
l'impression que les plus influents des
lobbys des lobbies pardon à rose autant
qu'ils le peuvent
les parlementaires cet amendement
reprend donc des propositions
d'associations de lutte contre la
corruption
il s'agit non pas de limiter ou
d'entraver les relations entre les
parlementaires et les représentants
d'intérêts mais de les rendre les plus
transparente possible de manière à ce
que les parlementaires et ses
représentants d'intérêts respecte les
règles les plus élémentaires de probité
à cette fin inscription dans un registre
des représentants intérêts devrait être
obligatoire dès lors qu'ils exercent
magnifique
comment une activité d' influence auprès
des responsables publics
de plus en faisant reposer l'obligation
de déclaration que sur les lobbyistes
cette disposition laisse les
administrations ou institutions libres
d'organiser comme elles l'entendent
leurs relations vis-à-vis des
représentants d'intérêts par ailleurs
enfin cet amendement propose à la haute
autorité d'émettre des recommandations
de anthologique
à propos des représentants d'intérêts
afin de concilier au mieux l'ouverture
de notre parlement sur la société civile
et la nécessaire indépendance de chacun
d'entre nous dans ses délibérations
si madame avis de la commission monsieur
le président la commission et l'asthme
dame thurman n'est pas favorable cet
amendement 53 que vous avez défendu avec
conviction parce que imaginer ce que
pourrait être un registre des
représentants d'intérêts au sein de la
république française nous non mais nous
considérons que le lobbying est un vrai
problème qu'il est sage que les
assemblées parlementaires leurs bureaux
et leurs organes de déontologie s'en
préoccupe
mais il est très difficile d'instaurer
par la loi
intel le un tel registre
ce qui me paraît tout à fait clair c'est
que il y a eu des dispositions qui ont
été prises ici même au sénat il en a
aussi qui ont été prises à l'assemblée
nationale je crois que cela va dans le
bon sens que c'est pratique et que c'est
maîtrisable par ailleurs pour éviter les
lobbyings lemieux et lorsque l'on fait
un rapport par exemple et nous veillons
tout ça cela c'est de recevoir toutes
les personnes que nous jugeons utile de
recevoir de publier la liste exhaustive
des personnes que nous recevons nous
décidons de recevoir qui nous voulons
nous procédons à toutes les auditions
nous maîtrisons la liste des gens que
nous recevons à part cela on peut des
gens peuvent solliciter des rendez vous
peuvent venir nous voir mais nous devons
appliquer une déontologie une éthique
les uns et les autres pour être
parfaitement indépendant ça n'empêche
pas qu'on entende ce qu'on nous dit mais
je ne crois pas et la commission ne
crois pas que la création d'un
gigantesque registre de représentants
d'intérêts ce soit la bonne méthode et y
avait du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
ma vie même avis défavorable je mets
donc on voit l'amendement 153 monsieur
collombat pour explication d'une
remarque je pense qu'effectivement en
tenir ce registre poserait quelques
problèmes enfin en l'occurrence
s'agissant de ceux de ce texte
sauf erreur de ma part les personnes qui
ont été auditionnées étaient quasiment
toutes favorables au texte
merci je le mets se voit quels sont ceux
qui sont pour l'adoption de l'amendement
153 de madame kuperman avis contraire il
n'est pas adopté le sens 25-22 rectifié
tombe
nous en arrivons à l'article 11 khater
de monsieur et un amendement 172 de la
commission monsieur le président il
s'agit d'un amendement de coordination
monsieur le président est favorable
favorable quels sont ceux qui sont pour
son adoption
avis contraire il est adopté
l'amendement de monsieur gorce tombe et
je mets au voile article11 khater quels
sont ceux qui sont pour son adoption
avis contraire il est adopté et nous
arrivons après l'article aux cater de à
l'amendement prendre de madame goulet
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues bis
repetita placent est il s'agit
exactement du même amendement que tout à
l'heure je vais simplement essayer de ne
pas brouiller un truc informe
il s'agit donc le président de la
commission nationale des comptes de
campagne et des financements politiques
puissent déclarer au service tracfin
traque fin dès qu'il a connaissance des
faits dont il soupçonne qu'ils sont en
relation avec une infraction à la
législation fiscale il s'agit exactement
de la même disposition que celle que
nous avons adoptée tout à l'heure il
s'agit d'une disposition est nécessaire
pour articuler les contrôles de tracfin
avec les diverses structures qui
s'occupent du contrôle et du financement
des partis politiques
merci à vis de la commission monsieur le
président monsieur le président il ne
m'a pas échappé que cannes amendement
similaire a été adoptée tout à l'heure
donc quel que soit l'avis de la
commission il me paraît très incohérent
que l'amendement identique que vous
venez de présenter le fus points adopté
par le sénat
même raisonnement favorable merci je le
mets dans convois quels sont ceux qui
sont pour l'adoption de la de
l'amendement 32 madame boulet avis
contraire il est adopté
article 12 le 68 tombe le 63 rectifié
monsieur y est
oui monsieur le président il
conviendrait que les membres de la haute
autorité soit soumis au secret
professionnel et les s'il ne respectait
pas il faudrait prévoir les peines
prévues à l'article 226-13 du code pénal
merci à vis de la commission monsieur le
président cet amendement est satisfait
par le projet de loi puisque au 21e
alinéa de l'article 12
il est d'ores et déjà inscrit les
membres de la haute autorité sont
soumises au secret professionnel à vis
du gouvernement monsieur satisfait par
le texte versez-y les retirer
mais au secret professionnel il faut
dire les sanctions si on ne le respecte
pas que je sache
bon je le retire il est retiré
merci 5 amendement faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune le 110 tombe le 158
rectifié mal à ça si oui merci monsieur
le président notre débat débat depuis
hier s'est beaucoup focalisé sur la
publication du patrimoine que nous
estimons pour notre part nécessaire mais
nous pensons aussi qu'il a trop laissé
de côté la question clé de l'observation
de l'évolution du patrimoine la mission
control de cette transparence a donc été
confiée à une autorité indépendante
même si nous approuvons ce choix à la
notion capitale d'un répondant sur une
autre notion doit être affirmée c'est
celle du pluralisme et ils ont en effet
imaginables et sa collègue qu'une haute
autorité chargée finalement de contrôler
la probité des élus puissent être
dépourvu de pluralisme la composition de
la haute autorité prévu donc pour le
texte dont nous discutons se résume pour
une part à des personnalités désignées
par des hauts magistrats qui ont été
nommés par le gouvernement actuel ou
passé ou par les présidents des deux
assemblées
nous savons tous ici que ce mode de
désignation ne permettra pas loin s'en
faut une représentation de l'ensemble
des sensibilités présente au parlement
et se résumera par une représentation
indirecte les deux grands partis
dominants la réalité celle là et chacune
et chacun le sait bien nous estimons
qu'il n'ya pas d'autres solutions pour
assurer le pluralisme que d'augmenter le
nombre de personnes désignées par le
parlement qui devront minoritaire dans
la hotte à son autorité
tel que nous le proposons enfin là la
règle de l'article 40 de la constitution
nous a contraints sous peine
d'irrecevabilité d'annoncer que ces
nouvelles personnalités ne seraient pas
rémunérées
si votre objectif était retenue il faut
ah évidemment prévoir des indemnités
pour garantir l'indépendance de tous les
membres de la haute autorité
alors monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
mini j'attends vos réflexions sur ce
point si vous aussi vous êtes en
désaccord avec notre proposition ce que
j'imagine comment estimez-vous possible
de garantir le pluralisme dans cette
haute autorité qui aura que cela plaise
ou non un haut pour ne pas dire un créé
au caractère politique je remercie six
amendements 190 et 195 du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre bien monsieur le
président de l'amendement 190 vive
proposé que soient désignés avec les
deux titulaires deux suppléants qui
serait désigné dans les mêmes conditions
afin d'assurer un fonctionnement qui
sont en fonctionnement le plus fluide
qui soit de la haute autorité
et pour ce qui concerne le seul
amendement 195
il vise
l'assemblée nationale a complété la
composition de la haute autorité en
prévoyant que les présidents des
assemblées nomme chacun une personne
qualifiée connaissant les problématiques
et les pratiques en matière de
déontologie la nomination de ces
personnes doit en outre être autorisé
par les commissions des lois et des
assemblées à une majorité majorité
renforcée des trois cinquièmes des
suffrages exprimés
en clair l'objectif du gouvernement est
que dès lors qu'on élit une personne aux
trois cinquièmes peut supposer que c'est
une personnalité relativement consensuel
qui est choisi par chacune des deux
chambres dès lors qu'on en choisir et 2
elle ferait davantage l'objet le cas
échéant d'un accord politique entre les
principaux groupes parlementaires
nous souhaitons que ces personnalités
qualifiées puisse être choisi au delà
des clivages partisans ce qui
justifierait qu'il n'y ait qu'une seule
pq par chambre qui viendrait s'ajouter
aux personnalités qui se re qui
composeraient d'ores et déjà issus de la
cour de cassation du conseil d'état et
la cour des comptes plus le président
choisi par le président de la république
mais avec la validation des assemblées
qui composeraient la haute autorité
indépendante voilà donc une personne par
choix si les amendements 95 11 rectifié
monsieur collomb bah oui
visiblement les les personnes qui ont
exercé les fonctions de gouvernement et
où un mandat parlementaire sont frappés
d'une indignité temporaire franchement
je ne vois pas c'est assez étrange ce
type de raisonnement dans la mesure où
il ya des modes de désignation qui sont
rouverts et si un consensus qui se fait
sur une personnalité même si elle a
exercé des formes des fonctions
gouvernementales ou fonction de
parlementaire c'est pas pour ça que ils
sont même pour trois ans frappé
d'indignité nationale
c'est quand même assez étrange que des
parlementaires puissent accepter ce type
de l'ostracisme enfin deux femmes ont
donc sebdou à la proposition de modifier
cet alinéa ses deux amis nerfs merci à
vis de la commission monsieur le
président sur les amendements dans la
masse à scier les amendements du
gouvernement sur monsieur collombat
alors l'amendement de madame à ceux ci
dont je comprend l'esprit est quelque
peu inflationniste car nous sommes avec
le texte de la commission
avec deux représentants par assemblée 2
pour l'assemblée nationale 2 pour le
sénat le gouvernement n'en avait prévu
qu'un et je vois qu'avec ces amendements
numéro 100 90 100 95
monsieur le ministre va s'échiner à nous
faire revenir à 1 par assemblée alors
madame assassi propose de passer de 2 à
comme il y a deux assemblées ça fait 12
et par voie de conséquence toutes les
autres catégories c'est à dire les
représentants du conseil d'état de la
cour des comptes
et de la cour de cassation passe de 2 à
4 c'est à dire qu'on arrive à 12 12 12
24 membres
voilà alors je pense que l'amendement de
madame assassi sera d'un appui très fort
pour m'aider à résister contre eux les
velléités de monsieur le ministre de
revenir à 1 alors que nous sommes nous
sommes arrêtés à deux quant à
l'amendement 91 de monsieur collombat
nous considérons que ce délai de viduité
de vacuité je ne sais pas comment l'on
dit ce mais non monsieur que l'on bat ne
dit pas des gros mots comme cela le
délai nécessaire après la cessation de
fonctions politiques pour être nommé
comme personnalité qualifiée au sein de
la haute autorité pour la commission
assure l'indépendance mais je n'en
conclut pas que lorsque l'on est oui oui
monsieur que l'on bat je connais votre
thèse oui oui mais je connais je connais
votre thèse n'est pas parce qu'on est
élu parce qu'on a été ministre coin
perdu toute capacité de raisonner de
manière autonome et indépendante
je connais tout à fait votre
raisonnement et permettez moi de le
saluer
tout en vous disant que la commission a
hélas été défavorable à votre amendement
91 merci il
oui monsieur le président donc sur le le
190 et 195 du gouvernement j'ai cru être
tout à fait clair nous ne voyons pas où
il est suppléant l'assemblée nationale
vous savez a supprimé 10 suppléants
considérant qu'il s'agissait d'une
activité à temps plein temps qu'elle a
supprimé ses suppliant alors je ne vois
pas pourquoi vous voulez remettre déçus
bien surtout que nous ne sommes pas
dupes de cette stratégie qui consiste à
dos vous ajoutez deux suppléants de
manière à supprimer par rapport au texte
de la commission deux titulaires c'est
d'habitude monsieur benoit mots vous
faites preuve d'une subtilité le
supérieur je ne dis pas que c'est pas
subtil mais je vous ai connues plus plus
agile en la matière merci monsieur le
ministre à vis du gouvernement sur
l'amendement 158 rectifié bon jeu non je
ne vais pas répondre sur le thème de
l'agilité je voudrais juste dire que
fictivement ne pouvons pas nous partager
le nid
le désir de damas à 6,2 d'augmenter le
nombre de membres neil désir monsieur
collomb ba de supprimer les dispositions
que nous considérons être des garanties
d'indépendance pour le délai de viduité
pour les personnalités qualifiées
raisons pour lesquelles nous avons deux
avis défavorable à ces amendements
restant cohérent avec la logique est
celle du gouvernement de donner un
format qui sont un format qui permet une
bonne gouvernance de la haute autorité
mais de se garantir de vendée risque un
jour de 2,2 manque d'assiduité la
présence de suppléants pour cette haute
autorité fonctionne et monsieur richert
pour explications de vote le président
moyer légion pas tout de même exprimé ma
non doute quant à l'avis défavorable de
la commission sur l'amendement de suka
longue collombat relatif à la durée de
trois ans parce qu'on voit bien cette
disposition les calquer sur les
dispositifs de déontologie qui sont
applicables aux professionnels qui ont
exercé des responsabilités d'autorité ou
de contrôle et qui ne peuvent pas
ensuite aller travailler dans des
entreprises ou dans d'autres entités qui
ont été placées sous leur autorité ou le
contrôle
je ne vois pas salissant d'une autorité
indépendante
comment quelqu'un qui a quitté le
parlement qui a quitté le gouvernement
serait en position quelle que soit la
durée de de falla date de sortie de ses
fonctions en quoi il serait en capacité
d'influencer les autres membres de la
haute autorité
donc qu'il y ait un petit délai de
battement je le comprends mais qu on
calque ce ce délai de trois ans sur une
situation où il ya eu effectivement
exercice d'autorité et où moi je pour
avoir un tout petit peu pratiqué cette
mission je me dis que parfois la durée
de trois ans est à peine suffisant
il me semble que ça pourrait être un
sujet sur lequel on
réduisent un peu qu'on dise un an par
exemple et surfe un brochet de jeu le
commentaire que je voulais apporter sur
richard je mets donc on voit
l'amendement 158 rectifié bis de madame
assassi quels sont ceux qui sont pour
son adoption
avis contraire il n'est pas adoptée sur
l'amendement 190 du gouvernement quels
sont ceux qui sont pour l'adoption du
190 avis contraire il n'est pas adoptée
même vote pour le 195 je mets aux
voileux 91 rectifié de monsieur
collombat quels sont ceux qui sont pour
son adoption
avis contraire il est adopté
l'amendement 64 rectifié tombe le 65
rectifié beast 2 bis de monsieur y est
alors attendez ils ont des compétences
un lait dans le domaine de l'est de la
la vérification des comptes quelques dj
plus quoi ben oui donc en plus ça on a
bien mis au csm un avocat à une
commission des comptes on peut leur
mettre un expert comptable
merci à vis de la commission monsieur le
président défavorable monsieur le
président merci à vis du gouvernement
défavorable je mets donc on voit
l'amendement 65 rectifié bis quels sont
ceux qui sont pour son adoption
avis contraire il n'est pas adopté le 66
rectifié tombe le 67 rectifié bis
monsieur y est il est retiré le 174 de
la commission monsieur le président en
sueur amendement de coordination buecher
président favorable du gouvernement
cet amendement est adopté il est adopté
je mets au voit donc non l'amendement
194 du gouvernement pardon merci
monsieur le président là encore c'est un
amendement pour
faciliter le fonctionnement de la haute
autorité dès lors qu' il pourrait y
avoir un nombre significatif de
déclarations et de 2,2 dossier que la
haute autorité devra contrôler et que
certains d'entre eux peuvent justifier
d'un traitement plus rapide parce qu'il
ne présente pas de difficultés
particulières ou ne soulève aucune
question de principe
la possibilité serait donnée pour la
haute autorité de fonctionner en
formation restreinte à partir d'un
collège de quatre membres désignés par
le président de la haute autorité voilà
le sens de l'amendement qui est destiné
à permettre un fonctionnement plus
fluide de la haute autorité dès lors que
nombre de dossiers importants pourrait
lui être soumis mais la commission sur
le président la commission n'a pas
examiné cet amendement toutefois à titre
personnel j'y serai favorable en
sollicitant une petite rectification
en effet l'amendement e 10 e la haute
autorité se réunie en formation plénière
toutefois l'initiative du président elle
peut se réunir en formation restreinte
composée de quatre membres désignés par
lui
ça donne au président une sorte de
pouvoir souverain de désigner eux quatre
personnes alors je propose une
rectification monsieur le ministre qui
serait à l'initiative du président elle
peut se réunir en formation restreinte
composée de quatre membres désignés par
la haute autorité
c'est à dire que c'est la haute autorité
elle même qui désigneraient ou alors
comme dit monsieur richard à juste titre
désigné en son sein mais par l homme
désigné en son sein alors je dis bien la
correction serait la suivante désigné en
son sein par la haute autorité à la
place de par lui
oui mais monsieur richard je me permets
de vous faire observer que si vous ne
mettez pas par la haute autorité
on pourrait comprendre que c'est désigné
en son sein par le président bon bout
des cheveux bien qu on m oui oui je veux
bien qu on m en son sein est entendu que
nous irons hautement que les travaux
préparatoires signifie que en son sein
cela implique que ce soit les membres de
la haute autorité qui désigne les quatre
membres de la commune de la formation
restreinte le seul ministre sous réserve
de ces précisions effectivement en son
sein signifie que c'est bien la haute
autorité qui désigne ces quatre membres
et nous acceptons de l'amendement du
rapporteur donc à l'amendement du
gouvernement
merci je vais donc mettre aux voix le
l'amendement qui devient 294 rectifier
quels sont ceux qui sont pour son
adoption avis contraire il est adopté je
vais aux voix l'article 12 quels sont
ceux qui sont pour l'adoption de
l'article 12 avis contraire
il est adopté article 13 avec
l'amendement 179 de la commission
monsieur le président coordination
monsieur le président merci avis
favorable du gouvernement
je le mets au voit quels sont ceux qui
sont pour l'adoption du 179 avis
contraire il est adopté un amendement 69
rectifié monsieur y est
la commission monsieur le président 69
rectifier je pense que le vote intervenu
tout à l'heure sur l'article 11 devrait
conduire au retrait de cet amendement
oui et nous l'amendement 112 tombe
l'amendement 20 rectifié de madame
boulet monsieur le président monsieur
mini c'est chaque collègue c'est un
amendement qui qui est relativement
important je vais vous dire pourquoi à
l'alinéa 9 2 du texte que nous examinons
aujourd'hui nous voyons que les
associations pourront être agréé par la
haute autorité pour pouvoir se porter
partie civile non inclus la haute
autorité pourra être saisi par don dans
les conditions par des associations se
proposant dans leur statut de lutter
contre la corruption qu'elle a
préalablement agréées
c'est à dire que la haute autorité va
pouvoir délivrer des agréments or dans
le texte que nous allons examiner dans
48 heures sur la lutte
enfin petit texte sur la lutte contre la
fraude fiscale et contre la grande
délinquance le titre est un peu pompeux
pour le texte enfin c'est le texte que
nous avons pour l'instant prévoir
précisément dans son article à alinéa 7
qu'un décret en conseil d'état fixera
les conditions d'agrément d'associations
de lutte contre la corruption qui
pourront se porter partie civile c'est à
dire qu'à 48 heures d'intervalle on
risque d'avoir des associations qui
n'auront pas le même type d'agrément
moi je propose que d'enfin cet
amendement propose que dans le texte que
nous votons aujourd'hui nous renvoyons
aux textes à venir de façon à ce que
l'agrément soit le même pour la haute
autorité et pour les associations qui
pourront se porter se porter partie
civile me semble pas tellement cohérent
que certaines associations puissent
saisir la haute autorité et d'autres
seulement se porter partie civile et
qu'éventuellement les critères
d'agrément soit différent donc il s'agit
simplement d'une harmonisation entre les
deux textes
ces avis de la commission sur le poser
dans la commission est attaché
ce que l'agrément soit délivrée par la
haute autorité et non par le pouvoir
exécutif
elle est donc défavorable à cet
amendement ercé avait du gouvernement
monsieur ministre défavorable un peu je
remercie question d'avoir d'ailleurs
deux agréments
merci je mets donc qu'on voie
d'amendement 20 rectifier il est retiré
je me revois l'article 13 qu'elles sont
ce qu'ils sont 293 193 du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président il toujours par souci de
cohérence avec les positions du
gouvernement le présente amendement
précise que les membres et rapporteur de
la haute autorité pourront consulter
dans les locaux des services fiscaux
compétent le dossier fiscal des
personnes soumises à son contrôle et de
leurs conjoints
ces avis de la commission monsieur le
président la commission n'a pas examiné
cet amendement et je monte je remets
donc à la sagesse du sénat
merci je vais donc consulté le sénat
qu'elles sont ce monsieur richard pont
donc je m'en remets à la sagesse du
sénat quels sont ceux qui sont pour
l'adoption de l'amendement du
gouvernement invite contraire il est
adopté même vote pour l'article 13
il est adopté après l'article 13 un
amendement 192 de la commission monsieur
le président cet amendement de la
commission vise à rendre non
communicables les documents
administratifs qui sont nécessaires à
l'exercice des missions de la haute
autorité ce qui permet que la loi du 16
juillet 78 ne puissent pas être utilisés
pour obtenir communication de documents
qui ne sont par ailleurs ni publié ni
communiqué dans le même temps cet
amendement réduit cette dérogation
principe de communes est de
communicabilité des documents
administratifs au strict nécessaire car
elle ne couvriraient plus l'ensemble des
documents détenus ou élaboré par la
haute autorité mais seulement sont
nécessaires à ses missions 1,6
relevant de l'organisation et du
fonctionnement normaux d'une autorité
administrative serait bien sûr
communicables merci à vis du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre a
rappelé merci je mets donc on voit
l'amendement de la commission
l'amendement 182 quels sont ceux qui
sont pour son adoption
avis contraire il est adopté un
amendement 17 de madame goulet oui
absolument
je vais défendre les deux en même temps
exactement le même objet l'ordre dans le
premier ou le 19 pour le concerne
puisque nous y étions les associations
qui ont dans leur objet là la fraude
fiscale ou la la dénonciation en face
les associations dont nous parlions tout
à l'heure qui seront ou pas agréé je
propose que ces associations qui dans
leurs statuts propose de lutter contre
la corruption
déclare annuellement un certain nombre
de choses dont les subventions
le montant des dons les l'origine le
nombre d'adhérents est en gros leur
patrimoine dans le cadre des auditions
que nous avons eues dans la commission
dans lequel nous avons reçu un certain
nombre de plateformes tout à fait bien
pensante et à un moment j'ai posé la
question de savoir comment elle était
financée et là nous avons eu des choses
assez imprécise et je ne vois pas très
bien la raison pour laquelle ces
associations très utile qui vont être
agréé deux fois puisqu'elle sera gré une
fois dans le cadre de la haute autorité
et puis une fois dans le cadre d'un
décret passerait à travers les mailles
du filet d'une d'une transparence qui
nous est réclamée à cor et à cri qui est
bien légitime
donc ça c'est le premier amendement et
il n'est pas
j'ai cité d'ailleurs dans l'exposé des
motifs le compte-rendu le procès verbal
de la commission des requêtes donc si
vous ne croyez pas sur parole ce qui
serait quand même dommageable
vous pourrez toujours regarder au procès
verbal d'audition de la commission
denquête du 22 mai 2013 terre solidaire
etc ordinaire et la coordinatrice des
pas de forme paradis fiscaux et
judiciaires
vous avez aussi le comité catholique
contre la faim et le développement tous
ces gens là à peu près 160 salariés et
nous ne savons absolument pas comment
ils sont financés je pense que ce serait
la moindre des choses non rue non plus
mais justement puisqu'on est dans la
transparence dans puisqu'on est dans la
transparence
soyons soyons dans la transparence
l'autre l'autre amendement l'autre
amendement est du même de relève du même
esprit mais il est aussi important pour
le texte qui va venir déposer dans le
texte contre la la grande délinquance et
la lutte contre l'évasion fiscale il
s'agit des associations qui proposent
dans leurs statuts de développer des
activités en relation avec la vie
politique sociale et culturelle d'un
état étranger non communautaires pour
des raisons de droit communautaire
ces associations sont tenues de procéder
au même type de déclaration parce que
vous avez sur le territoire national et
notamment dans le val d'oise un certain
nombre d'associations qui ont des moyens
absolument exorbitant quand on sait par
exemple le prix d'un d'un meeting à
villepinte et dont on se demande très
franchement comment ces gens qui sont
pas supposés avoir des revenus 10 des
subventions peuvent financer ce genre de
choses alors il ya autre chose
vous avez les associations culturelles
dans paris intra muros qui l'a aussi
manipule beaucoup d'argent avec des gens
qui aussi perçoivent des fonds de
l'étranger
tout ça n'est pas très transparent tout
ça n'est pas très clair et je pense que
ce texte constituera une occasion
extrêmement intéressante de remédier à
ces carences
merci avis de la commission sur le 17 et
le 19 monsieur le président oui la vie
est le même
même sur les deux amendements ces
amendements soumettent certaines
associations des obligations
déclaratives ce qui est assez éloigné de
l'objet du texte qui se limite aux
obligations de responsables publics
en outre il n'est pas certain que ces
obligations pesant uniquement sur
certaines associations parce qu'elle
souhaite développer des activités en
relation avec un état étranger hors de
l'union européenne respecte parfaitement
la liberté d'association garantie par la
constitution
aussi de la commission at elle donné un
avis défavorable à ces deux amendements
merci quel est l'avis du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre le même que
monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur y est pour explication de
vote
oui je pense que l'exemple donné dans
son est particulièrement malvenu madame
parce que toutes les associations qui
font appel à la générosité publique
je le rappelle leur compte contrôlé par
la cour des comptes aujourd'hui
non mais le ccfd c'est le cas alors ne
donnait pas les mauvais exemples
monsieur que l'on bat on peut
effectivement penser que l'amendement 17
et pas vraiment en rapport avec notre
objet par contre je trouve que
l'amendement 19 est tout à fait pile
poil dans notre problème puisque nous
sommes pour la transparence la fois la
première chose c'est que les
associations qui vont quand même avoir
des pouvoirs se porter partie civile
enfin et cetera non mais je parle de
l'amendement 17 qui est 19 pardon qui
concerne les associations qui se propose
de lutter contre la corruption
donc non me jette pas de soupçon sur ces
associations mais le moindre la moindre
des choses c'est que effectivement il ya
un minimum de connaissances concernant
leurs ressources
aussi le nombre d'habitants le nombre
d'adhérents
ça aussi c'est important si vous avez
une association qui est fort en forme et
d'une personne de sa femme et de sa
belle soeur ça fait un peu juste
donc je crois que enfin moi
personnellement j'ai aujourd'hui s'il
est maintenu votre l amendement 19 merci
monsieur madame boulet pardon ah bon
alors monsieur richard lange et trucs
que vous m'aviez demandé la parole
excusez moi je partage les objectifs de
l'amendement 17 et relatif aux
associations qui il on développe un
programme de relations avec un état
étranger mais je redoute qu' elle soit
vraiment enfin cette notion là seulement
à s'éloigner de l'objet du texte donc je
ne pouvais peut-être pas suivre madame
goulet en revanche sur article 19 filets
bien en relation avec notre texte mais
pour renforcer cette relation et pour
éviter tout risque constitutionnel
je pense qu'il faudrait dire une
association se proposant par ses statuts
lutter contre la corruption est
bénéficiaire de l'agrément de la haute
autorité
parce que c'est à celle là qu'il est
légitime de demander déclaration les
autres ce sont les associations libres
merci monsieur dit l'un merci monsieur
le président dans quelques jours nous
allons remettre avec le préfet du port
un rapport que nous a demandé madame la
ministre de la jeunesse et des sports de
la vie associative et de l'éducation
populaire concernant une revalorisation
de la charte d engagement réciproque qui
avait été signé en 2001 et donc dans ses
engagements réciproques
les associations s'engagent à faire plus
de transparence que actuellement donc je
crois que ces amendements vont dans ce
sens là
merci mme hamm goulet
ce président je suis minute je voulais
je voulais simplement répondre à
monsieur y est que j'avais absolument
rien de spécial contre les associations
mais c'est celle là qui dans le cas de
nos auditions n'ont pas donné de réponse
à ce moment là c'est pourquoi je les ai
cités mais non j'entends bien et pour ce
qui concerne les associations étrangères
malgré tout donc j'ai évidemment je
pense qu'il faut sous-amendé le 19 en
rajoute en bénéficiant de l'agrément ça
me semble tout à fait tout à fait
évident est tout à fait pertinent quant
aux autres justin un dernier mot pour
dire que vous avez comme un certain
nombre d'associations qui interviennent
dans la vie publique nationale et est
parfois de façon itérative
et donc comme on est dans la
transparence de la vie publique
je vais maintenir les deux amendements
si je vais donc les mettre aux voix en
commençant par l'amendement numéro 17
quels sont ceux qui sont pour l'adoption
du de l'amendement dit cet avis
contraire il n'est pas adopté je vais
mettre aux voix l'amendement 19 qui
pourrait être rectifiées est ainsi
libellé une association se proposant par
ses statuts de lutter contre la
corruption est bénéficiaire de
l'agrément de la haute autorité est tenu
de le déclarer annuellement
quels sont ceux qui sont pour l'adoption
de cet amendement rectifié 19 avis
contraire il est adopté
après l'article 13 non nous avons vu
l'article 14 un amendement 180 de la
commission monsieur le président il
s'agit d'amendements de précisions il en
va de même pour le 175 monsieur le
président merci beaucoup avait du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
favorable
favorable sur les deux amendements je
mets donc aux voiles 180 quels sont ceux
qui sont pour l'adoption du 180 avis
contraire même vote sur le 175 même vote
ils sont adoptés
je mets au voile article 14 quels sont
ceux qui sont pour l'adoption de
l'article 14 avis contraire il est
adopté article 15 même vote même vote il
est adopté
après l'article 15 amendements 114 tombe
nous en arrivons à l'article 16 avec un
amendement 142 qui tombe
je me revois l'article 16 quels sont
ceux qui sont pour son adoption
avis contraire il est adopté
après l'article 16-1 amendement 118 qui
tombe 1 119 qui tombe également et nous
en arrivons à l'amendement 157 de mal en
pis kerman oui quelques mots sur cet
amendement puisque initialement le texte
prévoyait bien évidemment que les
citoyens qui signalent aux dons autolog
ou à la haute autorité les situations
potentielles de conflit d'intérêts que
ses citoyens puissent être protégées
contre toutes représailles les
suppressions de ces dispositions mettent
en danger de fait les citoyens qui
viendraient signaler des situations à la
haute autorité et par là même très
certainement l'efficacité de cette
autorité
je ne m'en serais m'empêcher ici de
rappeler les mots de lacordaire qui
disait qu entre le fort et le faible
entre le riche et le pauvre entre le
maître et le serviteur c'est la liberté
qui opprime et la loi qui affranchit et
donc si nous voulons réellement qu'il
puisse y avoir ce travail de lanceurs
d'alert je mettrai le terme est entre
guillemets parce que je sais qu'il a
beaucoup fait défaut et donc de rendre
effectives les différentes dispositions
qui sont red bull
dans ce texte de loi il convient en tout
cas pour les législateurs que nous
sommes de prendre les dispositions pour
protéger contre toutes représailles ces
citoyens représailles qui peut se
traduire par des situations très
diverses de licenciement de recrutement
non aboutis ou de discrimination en
matière de rémunération ou autre dans sa
vie professionnelle ou dans sa vie plus
plus privé donc voilà en tout cas cessé
dans ce sens dans cet intérêt que nous
proposons l'amendement tel que rédigé
merci madame plus guère main à vis de la
commission monsieur le président nous
avons décidé de parler des lanceurs
d'alert dans le projet de loi relatif à
la fraude fiscale qui traite également
de ce sujet il nous est apparu peu
cohérent de traiter deux fois de ce
sujet et le projet de loi sur la fraude
fiscale sera examinée sur le rapport de
monsieur alain anziani
après demain donc après demain vous
pourrez exposer vos pensées sur ce sujet
et je suis sûr qu'elles seront
recueillies accueilli avec intérêt par
notre rapporteur
c'est avait du gouvernement monsieur me
proposerait volontiers le retrait au
profit de l'amendement du gouvernement
l'amendement 191 sur le lanceur d alerte
merci l'amendement ait retiré madame
kuperman et on va on va retirer à
l'amendement vous avez soutien à
monsieur mais vous voyez sur l'autre
amendement parce que je pense quand même
que ce cci-ci en tout cas important de
prévoir ces dispositions
ce qui n'empêche pas le débat que nous
aurons sur l'évasion fiscale en même
temps je crois que voilà chaque texte
à son travail législatif et je ne
présage pas de l'avenir je crois que
voilà nos séances étant des fois un
petit peu perturbé quant au déroulé
initialement prévu je préfère m'en tenir
pour reprendre d'autres expressions
d'hommes pieux comme saint thomas et je
ne crois que ce que je vois cela me
satisfera donc voila nous retirons avec
une stratégie de repli pour soutenir
l'amendement du gouvernement
merci l'amendement est donc retiré mes
chers collègues nous avons beaucoup
avancé
il reste dix huit amendements à examiner
dans certains vont tomber si vous en
êtes d'accord et si chacun est con si on
peut terminer le texte est-ce que vous
en êtes d'accord
alors nous continuerons article 17 avec
un engouement 191 du gouvernement bien
nous
visant à rétablir l'article 17 / lanceur
d' alerte pour redire qu'il ne s'agit
pas pour nous de délateurs il n'y a pas
d'intention de nuire mais la volonté au
contraire de satisfaire au bien commun
l'intérêt public ou général raison pour
laquelle nous voulons les protéger
les lanceurs d'alert dès lors que cette
notion a déjà été reconnu et protégé
notamment dans les domaines des risques
sanitaires et environnementaux je vous
rappelle à la suite de la sphère du
médiateur et de l'action notamment
d'irène frachon et c'est la raison pour
laquelle le gouvernement je n'en dis pas
plus le débat a déjà eu lieu
souhaite réinscrire l'article 17 dans le
texte qui nous est soumis merci monsieur
le ministre à vis de la commission
monsieur monsieur le président le
gouvernement parle d'une seule voix et
c'est une grande chance d'ailleurs qu'il
en soit ainsi et c'est pourquoi monsieur
le ministre lors de l'examen après
demain du texte sur la fraude fiscale le
gouvernement s'exprimera je ne peux pas
me tenir un discours différent à votre
égard de celui que j'ai tenus à l'égard
de madame qu kerman dont j'ai bien
compris qu'elle ne se fiait pas la
théorie des apparences ce qui justifie
son allusion à saint thomas
merci je me suis en diane et le texte
sur la fraude fiscale me sens beaucoup
plus précis et complet il prévoit
d'abord de protéger à la fois les
salariés du privé et les agents de la
fonction publique
ensuite il est plus précis parce qu'il
vise non pas une situation de conflit
d'intérêts mais des faits relevant d'une
infraction pénale soit un crime soit un
délit et les mesures de protection sont
également être mieux et non c'est que
dans ce texte dont moi j me semble qu'il
devrait me retirer cet amendement et
attendre maintenant non pas 48 heures
mais
trente six heures pour qu'on examine le
protection des lanceurs d'alerté en tête
sur la fraude fiscale
merci madame goulet s'est précisé le
ministre chaque coffret devrait pas voir
l'un de mes gosses testeurs là mais
enfin franchement vous avez deux types
d'agréments et vous voulez deux types
d'agréments et vous aurez qu un seul
type 2 dans deux lanceurs dallaire alors
moi je veux bien mais je voudrais qu'on
m'explique
merci monsieur richard n'est plus
exactement dans la mémoire le texte qui
est prévu pour le le texte relatif au
lanceur d'air qui est envisagée pour le
projet de loi relatif à la fraude
fiscale mais il me semble bien qu'il ne
couvrira pas certaines des situations
qui évoque l'amendement 191 du
gouvernement puisque il s'agira cette
fois ci de d'alerté une autorité
indépendante
donc moi je comprends tout à fait la
démarche du président sueur mais à ce
moment là il faut qu'ils souhaitent
entendu que les la situation propre aux
informations transmises à la haute
autorité pour la transparence de la vie
politique seront incorporés à la
disposition qui sera dans le dans le
texte fraude fiscale parce que ça ne se
recouvrent pas pour l'instant
merci l'amendement est maintenue
monsieur le ministre je le mets donc on
voit quels sont ceux qui sont pour son
adoption
avis contraire il n'est pas adopté je
vais mettre aux voix n'ont donc
l'article 17 est supprimé après
l'article 17 un amendement 162 manama
sassi a pu céder ce sont des
dispositions sur la réserve
parlementaire qui ont été adoptées dans
le projet de loi donc il est retiré le
suivant été retiré en séance
j'arrive en à l'amendement 80,15 qui
tombe à l'article 18 l'amendement 92
rectifié de monsieur collombat il s'agit
du même me propose même de proposer la
même disposition qui avait été adopté
dans la loi organique
s'agissant donc de la sincérité des
déclarations il y as faute dans la
mesure où la déclaration fait il y a une
comment dire c'est sciemment que il ya
eu dissimulation crois que ça ne prouve
pas c est ce qu on avait adopté déjà en
prob sur la loi organique temps à
l'organisme et rssi 135 de monsieur
zocchetto en effet avec l'article 18
nous rentrons dans le chapitre des
dispositions pénales c'est donc un autre
type de droit qui s'applique
nous avons ainsi enfin si nous votons
cet article ce sera l'occasion de créer
un nouveau délit et pour qui et délits
il faut qu'il y ait une intention il
faut qui est l'élément intentionnel
à mon avis il est absolument
indispensable de rajouter le mot
sciemment derrière lever leur verbe
pardon au m merci avec la commission sur
ces deux amendements monsieur le
président la commission est favorable à
ces deux amendements identiques monsieur
le président merci sagesse je les mets
au mois dans quels sont ceux qui sont
pour l'adoption de ces deux amendements
un lit contraire je n'en vois pas ils
sont adoptés amendement 70 rectifié
monsieur y est bidon comme nous l'avions
présenté pour la loi organique il s'agit
de limiter quand même les sanctions
complémentaires à l'inéligibilité et pas
les droits civils et de famille parce
que ça pourrait interdire d'être tuteur
et ses terrasses qui ne seraient pas
justifiées
merci à vis de la commission monsieur le
président de la commission sera le même
que pour la loi organique vous vous vous
en souvenez donc je solliciterai de
monsieur y est une rectification qui
consisterait à supprimer et temporaire
puisque de toute façon toutes les peines
en question sont forcément temporaire
elle ne saurait être éternelle monsieur
y est il ya deux fois temporaire au
début à la fin monsieur richard a
parfaitement raison d'accord monsieur y
est
sagesse je mets donc aux voix
l'amendement de monsieur y est qui
devient de 70 rectifié bis quels sont
ceux qui sont pour son adoption
avis contraire je n'en vois pas il est
adopté un amendement 181 monsieur sueur
coordination me choque binaire six avis
favorable du gouvernement oui je le mets
se voit quels sont ceux qui sont ou son
adoption
il est adopté je me revois l'article 18
quels sont ceux qui sont pour l'adoption
de l'article 18 avis contraire il est
adopté à l'article 19 l'amendement 115
tombant dans 129 de monsieur ans diane
et il s'agit simplement de rectifier un
visa dans le texte actuel on vise un
article 121 26 en fait il faut viser
l'article
on vise un article 136 mais il faut
viser non seulement cet article mais
également le centre 1,3126 un merci à
vis de la commission monsieur le
président la fort à bhl monsieur le
président mais ma vie même avis je le
vois quels sont ceux qui sont pour
l'adoption de cet amendement avis
contraire il est adopté
article 19 même vote il est adopté
article 19 bis la suppression est
maintenu à nous en arrivons après
l'article 19 bis un amendement 94 de
monsieur collombat alors là il s'agit de
quelque chose d'un petit peu différent
nous revenons sur un problème que
récurrents ont posé donc plusieurs fois
au sénat qui s'est traduit par au moins
deux vote à la majorité a comparé
consensus enfin donc au sénat sur une
définition donc
de la prise illégale d'intérêts qui soit
un peu plus fakih mettre à l'abri les
élus locaux de certaines situations
comme le fait pour quelqu'un qui
représentait ce qualité sa collectivité
dans une association et qui par malheur
aurait participé donc au vote d'une
subvention à cette association encore
une fois dans laquelle il est s qualité
d'être donc accusé de prise illégale
d'intérêt il ya des exemples il y aurait
donc de la cour de cassation qui ne fait
pas de distinction entre les intérêts
moraux et les intérêts particuliers donc
encore une fois à l'unanimité par deux
fois le sénat à l'unanimité par deux
fois le sénat à adopter donc cette
nouvelle définition que nous proposons
remplacé donc un intérêt quelconque par
un intérêt personnel distinct de
l'intérêt général et faute sait jamais
ce texte n'a été inscrit à l'ordre du
jour de l'assemblée nationale vue là la
méfiance dont témoignent ses traits ses
textes envers les élus locaux je crois
que ce serait la moindre des choses que
de d'améliorer le dispositif en matière
de répression donc de la prise illégale
d'intérêts merci à vis de la commission
monsieur le président fut les votes déjà
eux émis par le sénat par cohérence la
commission est favorable c'est avait du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
l'avis du gouvernement n'est pas
favorable pour
à cela d'abord parce que la notion
d'intérêt général donnera lieu à
l'instar de l' intérêt quelconque à nos
yeux à des interprétations qui sont très
subjective car son contenu peut varier
selon les temps les lieux et les
opinions de surcroît il nous voulons
souligner que cette modification
s'appliquera à l'ensemble des personnes
visées non pas seulement aux élus et
enfin l'expression d' intérêt personnel
distinct de l'intérêt général est en
plus restrictives que celles d' intérêt
quelconque cette clarification risque de
conduire à dépénaliser les situations où
l'élu favorise un tiers avec lequel il
n'a pas de liens personnels alors que le
lien d'ingérence est souvent dissimulées
par interposition d'autres personnes
considérées par la jurisprudence comme
complice donc défavorable
donc on voit monsieur collomb bah oui je
m'attendais bien toi je m'attendais ce
que vous me disiez c'est un mauvais
signe envoyé à l'opinion
je ne l'avais pas dit non non il ya deux
choses
il ya donc l'intérêt personnel
l'objection que vous présentez peut être
tout à fait recevable
par contre il reste l'intérêt général ou
la dir l'actif de fait l'action qui est
pro qui est fait est conforme à
l'intérêt général où elle n'est pas
conforme à l'intérêt général
donc si effectivement vous faire vous
favorisez une tierce personne
c'est pas du tout conforme à l'intérêt
général donc l'objection ne s'applique
pas merci jamais se voit donc cet
amendement 94 rectifié quels sont ceux
qui sont pour son adoption
avis contraire il est adopté
article 20 avec un amendement 101 qui
tombe un amendement 116 qui tombe et
nous en arrivons 93 rectifié de monsieur
collombat il s'agit de notre problème
qui a été évoqué tout à l'heure par
notre notre collègue
richard c'est le problème du pantouflage
et nous pensons que bondé l'aide de
trois ans avant pour quelqu'un qui a eu
des responsabilités dans un ministère
c'est un délai de trois ans pour
reprendre oui jeu discutable jeu pour
avoir une activité dans une entreprise
qui qui est à peu près les mêmes
enfin qu'il ya le même champ d'activité
ça nous paraît un peu court donc cette
proposition serait de de porter de 3 à 5
ans le délai étant entendu que bon ce
texte n'aborde pas cette question-là du
pantouflage ou à l'envers il ya le
pantouflage à l'envers aussi c'est à
dire que un élu qui est battu et aurait
recueilli dans une couveuse la couveuse
une grande entreprise et une fois réélu
se trouve que parfois les marchés vont à
ladite entreprise ça c'est une pratique
qui est quand même pas c'est pas
courante mais qui peut s'observer de ci
de là
donc bon c'est un problème difficile
parce que effectivement à régler mais
donc sur ce problème du pantouflage
nous proposons d'allonger le délai de
trois à cinq ans
ces avis de la commission sur le
président en est actuel des informations
de votre rapporteur
il ne paraît pas s'imposer d'augmenter
ce délai l'article 20 du projet de loi
se limite en cohérence avec des
dispositions comparable du projet de loi
relative à la lutte contre la fraude
fiscale aggravé les peines c'est
pourquoi je demande le retrait à
monsieur collomb bas à défaut je serais
défavorable avait du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
en dépit de ce signe que vous donnez
monsieur colombes à l'opinion le
gouvernement y est défavorable
merci je vais donc mettre aux voix
l'amendement 93 rectifié de monsieur
collombat quels sont ceux qui sont pour
son adoption invite contraire il n'est
pas adopté je mets au voile article 20
quels sont ceux qui sont pour l'adoption
de l'article
20 avis contraire il est adopté même
vote sur le 21 mai mme vote sur 22 idem
sur le 22 bis à sur le 22 bis sur le 22
ter après l'article 22 ter amendement 22
il tend amendement 136 rectifié de
monsieur kétou oui c'est un amendement
qui propose de compléter la sanction
d'inéligibilité prévue par l'article 19
du projet de loi alors il s'agit pas de
proposer une peine complémentaire mais
de définir des conditions d'aptitude à
savoir que nul ne pourrait être candidat
à une élection
si le bulletin b 2 de son casier
judiciaire fait mention d'une
condamnation pour des infractions
traduisant un manquement au devoir de
probité ou des infractions de corruption
trafic d'influencé recel ou blanchiment
ça éviterait ainsi le triste spectacle
de de réélection d'élus condamnés alors
je précise que évidemment il s'agirait
pas d'une condition d'aptitude
définitive puisque ces sanctions
disparaissent au bout d'un moment du du
casier judiciaire
voilà merci monsieur le président
amendement 159 rectifié madame pic
herman l'amendement va dans le même sens
la rédaction est quasi et kelly la même
en tout cas dans la proposition dre de
rédaction de l'article du code électoral
154 je crois en tout cas à travers cet
article qu'il s'agit ici d'assurer que
les de s'assurer par donc les
représentants du peuple au dessus de
tout soupçon et que ne puisse être
candidat des citoyens des citoyens
condamnés par exemple pour des faits de
corruption de détournements de fonds
publics
donc je crois que cela s'inscrit dans
l'objectif de ce texte elle qu
initialement proposé à notre à notre
assemblée faire effectivement une
république exemplaire et dont nous
pensons que les élus doivent aussi
l'être bien évidemment merci à vis de la
commission monsieur le président sur ces
deux amendements
tels qu'ils sont écrits de ces deux
amendements constitue une inéligibilité
à caractère définitif ce qui pose un
réel problème constitutionnel
c'est pourquoi la commission était
favorable à ces deux amendements perd 6
à vis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
même avis que monsieur sueur pour le
caractère manifestement automatique et
non individualisées de la peine qui
présentent un risque constitutionnel
important merci je mets donc les mettre
aux voix quels sont ceux qui sont pour
l'adoption de ces deux amendements avis
contraire ils ne sont pas adoptées nous
en arrivons donc à l'article 23 avec un
l'amendement 71 rectifié de monsieur y
est
il est retiré je mets au voile article
23 quels sont ceux qui sont pour
l'adoption de l'article 23 avis
contraire il est adopté
même votre pour le 23 bis même vote pour
le 24 près je vais mettre aux voix
l'ensemble du projet de loi y at il des
explications de vote
je n'en vois pas je mets donc aux voix
l'arctique l'ensemble du projet de loi
relatif à la transparence de la vie
publique
quels sont ceux qui sont pour son
adoption avis contraire
le projet de loi est adopté mes chers
collègues je vous donne lecture de
l'ordre du jour du mardi 7 juillet à
14h30 et le soir projet de loi b
habilitant le gouvernement à simplifier
les relations entre l'administration les
citoyens deuxième lecture du projet de
loi relatif aux attributions du garde
des sceaux des magistrats du ministère
public en matière de politique pénale et
de mise en oeuvre de l'action publique
la séance est levée et je souhaite une
bonne nuit
voilà pour cette séance qui s'est
terminée ce matin à 2h15 je vous
rappelle que les sénateurs ont donc voté
à les deux projets de loi sur la
transparence de la vie publique sans
toutefois donner leur feu vert à la
principale disposition de ce texte à
savoir à la publication au journal
officiel du patrimoine des élus députés
et sénateurs vont se retrouver ce soir
pour trouver une solution de compromis
sur ces textes qui sont la réponse du
gouvernement à la sphère cahuzac très
bonne journée à tous